on en parlait en début d'émission
vendredi 17 mars l'association
Solidarité nationale pour le handicap et
les militaires blessés organisent un
gala de charité pour soutenir des
projets au service du vivre ensemble
pour en parler de militaires Vincent
Dorival et Nicolas éteint alors pour
ceux qui n'étaient pas là en début
d'émission avec nous je le rappelle
Vincent de rival vous avez été blessé
dans l'exercice de vos fonctions et vous
Nicolas hit un vous êtes le père d'un
enfant trisomique alors à travers cette
soirée quel est le message que vous
souhaitez faire passer
de sensibiliser sensibiliser sur les
étudiments sur les différents
thématiques qui vont être abordées lors
d'une table ronde ce soir là donc à
savoir les militaires blessés et
réinsertion justement pour eux
il y a également donc tout ce qui est
inclusion que ce soit l'inclusion
l'insertion professionnelle des
personnes en situation de handicap mais
aussi l'éducation qui justement qui mène
à l'insertion professionnelle c'est
finalement c'est tous ces projets c'est
neuf projets qui seront représentés ce
soir là parleront de ces trois
thématiques
c'est ça c'est l'association
ultra Ops que j'ai l'honneur de présider
qui a donc depuis 2018
elle a pour mission de du moins d'objet
en tout cas de de prendre des blessés
avec une dominante force spéciale mais
aussi des gens des transmissions des
pompiers de Paris du GIGN pour la
gendarmerie service de santé des armées
avec des infirmiers conserviers en
compagnie de combat
et les gens étrangères voilà l'idée
c'était de d'être le plus représentatif
possible de prendre ces gens qui ont été
blessés au combat pour la plupart
et de leur montrer qu'ils ont une
plus-value que leur blessure a une
plus-value et que ils sont encore en
capacité de faire de grandes choses et
du coup on les met en difficulté on fait
exprès
en les engageant sur des traversées de
désert en mode dégradé parce qu'on
avance avec un bivouac et l'idée voilà
ce au fur et à mesure que qu'ils
enchaînent les kilomètres mais qui
puissent s'apercevoir qu'ils sont encore
en capacité de réaliser de grandes
choses du coup ils reprennent confiance
en eux et voilà c'est c'est à partir de
ce moment là où ils entrent dans dans ce
dans cette difficulté il tente de d'en
sortir et il faut qu'il reste sur cette
dynamique cette positivité et voilà donc
on a des gens aussi en syndrome pods
chromatique
qu'on diagnostique de de mieux en mieux
et de plus en plus malheureusement
voilà donc il se servent de cet
événement là pour rebondir c'est un
tremplin finalement
de réinsertion soit en unité ou soit à
la reconversion professionnelle un beau
projet en tout cas Nicolas hit un il y a
d'autres projets qui vont être proposés
aborder lors de ce gala est-ce que
pareil vous pouvez nous les présenter
Paris du projet que je représente
également
donc avec mon épouse on a créé il y a
deux ans l'association dans tes pas qui
qui a pour but de créer une petite école
pour des jeunes avec une déficience
intellectuelle j'ai 12 à 18 ans une
petite école innovante en fait qui
se placerait entre les IME les instituts
médicaux éducatifs et Les Ulis les
unités localisées d'inclusion scolaires
de façon à apporter justement à ces
jeunes
des apprentissages adaptés avec un
encadrement on va dire plus présent et
plus justement plus important pour
pouvoir vraiment individualiser les
apprentissages pour ces jeunes de façon
à les guider à les accompagner dans leur
projet de vie et leur donner les bons
outils pour une inclusion réussie
donc voilà c'est un des 9 projets qui
sera présenté il y a également d'autres
projets
un projet sur une ferme qui veut être
créée justement pour embaucher et faire
vivre des jeunes en situation de
handicap
justement dans un cadre
pleine nature avec un travail spécifique
mais justement dont ils sont capables de
faire de façon les épanouir avec le
contact des animaux dans d'autres tâches
voilà après d'autres projets encore liés
justement au militaires sur la
réservation par le sport
qui seront pris qui sont présentés ce
soir-là et alors ce gars
il regroupe plusieurs associations vous
êtes une dizaine d'associations il me
semble c'était important d'avoir ces
nombreux acteurs là c'est l'union fait
la force sans quelque sorte
de montrer qu'on travaille ensemble
justement pour cette même cette même
problématique de façon à sensibiliser
les gens sur sur ce vivre ensemble sur
cette inclusion sur ces différentes
thématiques qu'on a abordées et donc
vous avez aussi de nombreux soutiens
puisqu'il y a vous avez la pluie du
ministère des personnes handicapées et
également de l'armée de l'air
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que ça signifie
pour vous de ben voilà d'être appuyé par
par des grands
on fait partie de la même société
vous avez un côté donc
l'état-major de l'armée de l'air à côté
un
patronat du ministère de en charge de
l'handicap voilà donc ça montre
finalement qu'on fait partie de la même
société qu'on avance sur les mêmes
problématiques on a des réponses voilà
on travaille ensemble
c'est le meilleur exemple de de pour
montrer
une façon d'être inclusif et voilà dans
dans la société que finalement on
partage et ce pourquoi le l'idée
effectivement de de rassembler des gens
qui viennent de domaine différents mais
bon quand on parle du handicap
finalement on arrive à se retrouver et
avancer dans le dans le même sens et
vous avez également trois par un alors
il y a Thomas Lombard le directeur de du
général du Stade Français il y a Charles
Rodwell le député de la première
circonscription des Yvelines et Fabien
offrechter le maire de
Verneuil-sur-Seine vous avez pu échanger
avec eux et pourquoi est-ce qu'ils ont
décidé de soutenir ce gala de solidarité
je pense qu'ils sont sensibles justement
cette thématique et voilà ils veulent
ils veulent s'investir ils veulent
donner du crédit justement à notre
démarche et voilà nous aider justement à
faire connaître ces différents projets
et
à développer justement ce type
d'initiative
comment on commence à se passe pour
assister à la soirée tout le monde peut
venir ou
non c'est sur invitation en fait voilà
il y a des invitations qui ont été
lancées donc auprès de délu auprès
d'associations auprès d'entreprises
et en fait c'est vrai que l'objectif de
la soirée d'une part donc comme je vous
disais c'est de sensibiliser justement
sur cette thématique mais également de
lever les fonds justement pour les
différents projets qui ont besoin de
soutien financier pour pour pouvoir
avancer sur leurs différents projets et
vous attendez combien de personnes pour
l'instant on espère accueillir 200
personnes ce soir
et bien merci Vincent endorival et
Nicolas est un d'avoir répondu à nos
questions